when you are excellent you become
unforgettable your heart says I need to
go up and do this this is the right
thing to do and your brain says this is
stupid you can't spend the entire day
helping one person you got so many other
things to do if you do the right thing
regardless of what the consequences are
that that represents character rise and
shine it's an espresso time what's up
believe nation it's Evan this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine and help you believe in
your Michael Jordan level talent so
let's start your day off right together
grab your coffee and sip on today's
message always do the right thing over
to you Oprah Winfrey also if you want to
know what Oprah and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below I have paid
attention to my life because I
understand that my life just like your
life is always speaking to you the real
work is to figure out where your power
base is
always do the right thing always be
excellent people notice think of how you
notice you go to Taco Bell somebody
gives you extra napkin and some sauce
you notice you want to go back to that
person cuz even at Taco Bell excellence
shows itself be excellent let excellence
be your brand
everybody talks about building a brand I
never even knew what that was when
people say you're a brand I would say no
I'm just Oprah what I recognize now is
that my choice
to it every way in every example in
every experience to do the right thing
and the excellent thing is what has
created the brand years ago I did an ad
for Revlon for for an ad they were doing
called unforgettable women and what I
know is that when you are excellent you
become unforgettable people remember you
you stand out regardless of what it is
you become an unforgettable woman and
that is what we all want we want to be
unforgettable and not forgettable so
doing the right thing even
when nobody knows you're doing the right
thing
we'll always bring the right thing to
you I promise you that
why because the third law of motion is
always at work for every action there's
an equal and opposite reaction that is
so true in all of our lives the key to
getting ahead is doing your current job
well excellence is doing the thing that
you're doing right now the thing that's
right in front of you doing it well so
many entrepreneurs are so focused on the
big picture you're so focused on scaling
you're so focused on how do I get
millions of people on my mission I want
to accomplish something big I want to
grow it to the moon which is amazing and
it's awesome and that will motivate you
to keep going and it's in doing the
small things that are right in front of
you on a daily basis in an excellent way
that anything that you are spending your
time on if you are spending five minutes
doing something you are gonna do it in
an excellent way you are stamping your
brand of excellence on everything that
when you are involved in a project your
effort will be excellent now the problem
with this is sometimes it feels like
it's not ROI positive to do something to
help one customer to spend an entire day
helping one customer may not feel like
it's gonna be ROI positive and that's
where the brain and the heart start to
fight the head and the heart start to
fight your heart says I need to go up
and do this this is the right thing to
do and your brain says this is stupid
you can't spend the entire day helping
one person you got so many other things
to do listen to your heart doing the
right thing is always the right thing so
a quick example I was on an Instagram
live and I was set to finish my
Instagram live I go live four times a
week answering questions and I had like
three minutes left before I was set to
expire I had to move on to something
else
and I had a live caller come in and she
wanted help and I loved her I could
sense the need
I get since she was on that something
important that was sense that what I
could give her in the time that we
together would be valuable that she
would use it that she would take that
information and apply it I I had to stay
on with her and ended up talking to her
for at least another 15 20 minutes over
my extended time over when I was
supposed to cut off I had lots of other
projects to do lots of other people to
get back to and yet I pushed all those
things to talk to her because my heart
said it was the right thing to do
because I felt like the right thing to
do even though my head said this is a
waste of time where is the ROI now a
week later she ends up signing up for
the workshop that I had in Toronto I
have a workshop that twice here I put on
to help people make money from their
ideas as a thought leader to make money
from brand deals and book deals and
speaking gigs and courses and all of
this how to make money doing that for 10
to 15 people she ended up signing up for
that now which she have signed up if I
didn't spend that 15 20 minutes overtime
with her maybe maybe not and there's
lots of other people as well who I spend
an insane amount of time with and they
never end up buying anything it's still
the right thing to do now you might be
watching saying well that's great but I
need to make money I need to make this a
business I'm here because I need to put
food on the table and build my company
up and I can't just spend all day long
helping one person at a time so I'm
gonna give you three things to think
about around making the right decision
and how to use that so it does become an
ROI positive activity in your business
number one is decide what does the right
thing look like to you what does it mean
to you the reason why I stuck on with
that woman for so long was because my
one board is believe yes I changed my
shirt is something else now but believe
is still here believing is still down
there my one word is believe and I
believed in her and I wanted to see it
through and so if you understand what
your one word is it gives you the
framework to understand what is the
right thing to do when is it worth going
all-in on that thing and so for me if I
can help somebody believe in themselves
believe in their Michael Jordan level
talent then I have to do it I have to do
it and it will end up being positive
enough if I consistently do it one
person may not pay it back but if I can
consistently do it enough people will
and my business will rise and on top of
that it just feels good when you know
what you staying for and you inject that
into other people and you are helping
them build and grow themselves it just
feels good it feels great for yourself
and it becomes ROI positive so it starts
with understanding what your one word is
what your most important core value is
and that can help frame your decision as
to what doing the right thing looks like
for you tip number two is flex T X this
is the X whenever there is a goal that
I'm trying to set a habit that I'm
trying to set for myself that is
difficult for me to ingrain that is not
quite happen on a daily basis yet I put
on the calendar this is my annual
calendar and I mark an X off for every
consecutive day that I do it and I don't
want to miss it I want to make sure that
I get that X down every day and so how
do you make sure you're doing the right
thing and how do you make sure that
that's consistent put it on your
calendar flex the X every single day
you're spending a little bit of time at
least helping one person and doing the
right thing so doing the right thing
we've defined what that looks like for
you through your one more core value
then are you living it are you doing it
are you injecting that into the world
flex the X every time you do it at least
once a day
you put that X on the calendar and if it
hasn't happened by the end of the day
then you got to do something you gotta
find the way so for me believing in
people is just default standard now it
happens so often I'm meeting people all
the time I'm creating videos and
answering comments and multiple times
per day I just can't help it but it was
a habit that you're trying to build up
around your one word then by the end of
the night if you haven't done it then
you have to find somebody that you can't
believe in or help inspire or help
educate or help provide some excellence
to like whatever your one word is make
sure every single day you are flexing
the X and finally number three is be the
tree and this is a mindset shift see a
lot of people will think well I'm
providing all this value I'm helping
people I'm doing the right thing and
it's not paying back I'm not getting the
return it's not happening fast enough
for me I help this person out I gave
them everything I had and I don't even
get a thank you let alone somebody buy
my product or hiring me as a consultant
or whatever it is that you're trying to
sell
breathe I try to see myself as a tree I
think once you discover what your one
Ward core value is then you are a tree
your responsibility is what does it tree
do breeze in the poison a tree breathe
in carbon dioxide which is poison it's
poison to us a tree Bryza then eats it
grows from it and then spits out oxygen
that's what I see as my role and your
role when you discover what you are all
about then your job is to breathe in the
toxic around you eat it grow from it and
then spit out positivity spit out
believe spit out whatever your one word
is it's your responsibility and so if
some people are not grateful if some
people don't recognize you if some
people don't even say thank you that's
okay because that's part of your role
you're breathing in the poison you're
growing and you're spitting out oxygen
and some people will grow from it will
love it we'll use it we'll hire you and
your business will take off now I've got
a really special bonus clip that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that
question of the day I want to know what
is one right thing that you can do for
somebody in your circle today let me
know put it down in the comments below
you know for me character is not a very
complex thing for me character is you do
what's right you do what's right you do
the right thing that's what you do and
if you do the right thing regardless of
what the consequences are that that
represents character and so then how do
you build character it's a beautiful
thing because it's the same thing if you
want to build character you do the right
thing you do the right thing for
yourself you do the right thing for your
family you do the right thing for your
the people that you know you do the
right thing for your community you do
the right thing for your country that's
what you do and now on an individual
level
those things are hard things often right
if those are hard things you have to
make the right decisions you have to
live a disciplined life those build
character those little things that you
do on a daily basis to make yourself
better to improve your health to improve
your your situation in life you're doing
those things they're hard to do and when
you do those things they build your
character and ultimately they lead to
your character being a good character as
opposed to a bad one people told me that
I might not be able to to do well in
school for whatever reason I was always
a good student I worked hard but I
thought there was some magic that
happened that made you really I didn't
know that it was just plain old hard
work so there were periods of doubt for
sure I think we all I have doubts today
doubts don't go away you just learn how
to deal with them you you start knowing
yourself and you become more confident
the more successes you have the more
chances you take the you don't let the
the failures or the stumbles define you
now everybody Falls every now and then
some people fall a lot and what I
realize is that we have long lives if
we're healthy and
we do what we're supposed to do I'm 47
years old so think about it well
whatever mistake I made when I was 13
who cares
so think about life as a long trajectory
but at the same time you don't want to
make huge mistakes because when you're
young making big big mistakes can last
forever all right so you want to choose
wisely
but the stumbles the lessons learned
that's part of life that that makes you
grow but I I came to know that I didn't
know that when I was your age I thought
every every mistake was the end of the
world I'll never be able I'll never get
into school I'll never be you know of
course we all feel that way but just
continue to work put the put the effort
in and I think that has been some of
what's helped me being first lady
perfect first of all is knowing who you
are and being confident in yourself
because they'll be clear as to what it
is that pushing beyond other people's
labels of you all right that's a big
part that's what we do to each other all
the time we don't even know each other
and we already determined from one
glance meeting one line one word one
phrase this is who you are so you have
to know who you are before that and you
and you live that reality and you keep
living it out no matter what and if
you're a good have good character and
and good intentions that that ultimately
shines through but in the end it's hard
work and I'd like to work hard and I'd
like to do good things and you practice
that now and believe it or not I didn't
know it it prepared me to be the first
lady of United States I didn't know I
guess I'm doing okay but you know what
every day we just get up and keep doing
what we think is the right thing raise
your standard cool
it's core value is that we believe that
people with passion can change the world
not one drop of myself work depends on
your it's something serene if you want
to learn more for Oprah and some of her
biggest life lessons check out the video
next to me I think you're gonna really
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there
I had a boyfriend I would say let's just
go for a ride I want to know where are
we going